[Musique]
non
bonjour bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 culture tout de suite le sommaire
un jouer meneur pour assister à
plusieurs concerts c'est le concept
original qui a été proposé à la batterie
à guyancourt sur scène johnny montreuil
ou encore didier wampas
retour sur ce concert pour la bonne
cause et découvertes dans cette émission
du groupe dell grèce de passage aux
prises miles en cours le trio de
musiciens est venu faire découvrir son
album aux accents de blues caribéen
nous prendrons la direction de la scène
nationale du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son directeur
lionel masse et à vous présentera un de
ses prochains spectacles coup de coeur
il s'agit des stones ouest avec la
chorégraphe josef weiss un concert un
peu spécial s'est déroulée le 30
novembre dernier à la batterie de
guyancourt sur scène les musiciens des
studios johnny montreuil ou encore
didier wampas qui étaient réunies pour
une bonne cause
reportage ces musiciens qui répètent
habituellement dans les studios de la
batterie de guyancourt sont réunis
devant près de 200 personnes pour un
concert un peu particulier pour cette
soirée dénommée les studios ont du coeur
aucun billet n'était en vente
il suffisait simplement de ramener un
jouet neuf j'ai emmené une barbie bas
pour l'association pourra voir le
concert show c'est une bonne initiative
donc joint l'utile
ça permet à des enfants d'avoir un noël
comme tout le monde
parrain de cette soirée caritative
johnny montreuil avec son groupe le
chanteur est venu présenter son dernier
album narvalo forever sorti en avril que
tu es là sur scène ce qu'on raconte à tu
as un truc très rock'n roll très rock
même qui peut aller vraiment tu peux
aller vraiment dans du lourd mais on
essaie vraiment de mettre toujours les
textes en avant donc il ya toujours un
petit truc sautillant il ya toujours un
gros clin d'oeil à nos grosses
références à obili à johnny cash à cette
country là en fait c'est pas la musique
country c'est un mec qui racontait des
trucs sur cette musique là parmi les
autres invités de la soirée le groupe
sugar en tiger avec didier wampas
pourquoi
le chanteur est un habitué de ce type
d'initiative et n'a pas hésité à monter
sur la scène guyancourt toise on est
content de jouer déjà et en plus quand
c'est pour une bonne cause c'est encore
mieux c'est pas vraiment de s'engager
pour un événement c'est 2 comment dire
d'être présent et puis de faire riquiqui
quelque chose derrière pour toi tu
sèches pourrait détourner
je marchais droit
on a déjà fait des concerts entre
guillemets de soutien à d'autres causes
aussi
enfin la musique c'est un chouette
vecteur pour rapporteur pour rassembler
des gens autour d'une idée quatre
associations ont pu récupérer les deux
cents jouets récoltés lors de cette
soirée
ils seront distribués pour noël aux
enfants dans le besoin
vous le savez régulièrement dans cette
émission les directrice ou directeur d
établissement culturel de saint quentin
en yvelines vous présentent leurs coups
de coeur
cette direction aujourd'hui le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec son
directeur lionel masse et à juste avant
les fêtes de noël nous aurons la grande
chance d'accueillir une chorégraphe qui
s'appelle de joseph beuys une
chorégraphe qui n'a jamais été
accueillie au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et pourtant ça
fait bien trente ans maintenant quelle
oeuvre dans les quartiers nord de
marseille
son travail consiste tout simplement à
accueillir des enfants à partir de l'âge
de 8 ans 9 ans à les former et à les
garder jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans avec ses
enfants et il travaille sur les
chorégraphies de grand soin des
problématiques et les crues soit des
chorégraphies qu'elles commandent à de
grands chorégraphes à travers le monde
soit des chorégraphies qui existent et
qui sont emblématiques de la danse
d'aujourd'hui
le spectacle s'appelle d'est en ouest
parce qu'on parcourt le monde à travers
la danse contemporaine
ce sera juste avant les fêtes de noël
d'est en ouest c'est le groupe grenade
et c'est la chorégraphe josette baïz
[Musique]
et puis
de la musique à présent leur nom de
groupe est un hommage à louis delgres
est ce une figure emblématique de la
lutte contre l'esclavagé en guadeloupe
le trio caribéen d'elle greffe était en
concert au prisme à elancourt pour faire
découvrir au public son album mojo dit
moi je suis d'origine guadeloupéenne et
je suis une enfance hexagonal et j'ai
entendu parler de louis delgrès ce
relativement tard dans ma vie et à un
moment où j'étais en plein de
questionnements personnelle par rapport
à mon identité ma place dans ce vaste
monde
et bien cette figure et mes revenus la
figure de louis delgres s et j'ai
commencé à faire des premiers sons de
blues ayant chanté en créole en pensant
à lui on en a tous un lien avec la
guadeloupe dans ce groupe parce que
baptiste est de nantes et donc
historiquement il ya un lien fort avec
les antilles françaises
et moi j'ai un lien plus personnel sur
mes parents m'ont conçu en boîte oui
mais ben moi je suis nantais donc
effectivement tout tout ce port nantais
a eu un lien super fort et voilà
dramatique aussi avec avec les antilles
oui c'est un album qui est engagé mais
il n'est pas engagé que pour les
descendants d'esclaves pour les
guadeloupéens pour les martiniquais
puisque on se rend bien compte que
finalement la figure de louis delgrès ce
déjà et même si quelqu'un qui était
métis vraiment quelqu'un de très très
moderne dans à la fois le personnage
mais aussi dans sa démarche
et puis son idée de la liberté c'est une
idée qui contemporaine qui est encore
très importante et à défendre
aujourd'hui donc on se rend compte au
fur et à mesure qu'on joue qu on
rencontre les gens que ça va bien au
delà de juste une revendication pour une
petite île ou autre c'est quelque chose
dans lequel tout le monde se retrouve
c'est la liberté d'être qui on est
d'assumer toutes les parties mais de qui
on est non défense a vraiment tous les
jours dans nos concerts
il ya aussi un peu d'anglais et un peu
de français aussi par exemple survivre
sur la route on utilise le français
voient la danse est un mélange mais
effectivement il ya quand même quelque
chose d un enracinement en allant créole
et c'est ce qui fait l'unicité de ce
groupe et on est les seuls à faire ça on
s'est rendu compte de ça on est seul à
mélanger les choses de cette manière là
ce blues avec ce côté rock à la fois et
toujours en toile de fond des fois
d'aider des guitares un peu mandingue
l'afrique n'est jamais très loin mais
vraiment on est dans le temps dans le
bayou aussi dans le sud des états unis
donc oui et ça voyage au niveau tant au
niveau des langues que de la musique
c'est un pli for pli for c'est moins
fort gestamp est pas encore
ou moins karpaty dit on priait pour un
[Musique]
autre univers avec les voca people pour
célébrer leur disant avec le public
français
le groupe qui chante a cappella sera au
théâtre de poissy ce sera le 11 décembre
à 20h30
[Musique]
le 10 décembre prochain la bévue de l'ue
vs qu à guyancourt accueillera une
exposition autour de josé et du festival
de cannes en 1939 documents d'archivés
images de l'époque et table ronde pour
évoquer l cette édition un peu
particulière
jean zay à uvrer pour la culture et
notamment pour les bibliothèques de
mettre également en valeur ce personnage
son oeuvre une partie de son oeuvre et
son engagement politique et culturelle
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée en effet de
créer le festival de cannes pour
contrecarrer la mostra de venise qui
était évidemment sous la main des du
pouvoir fasciste non seulement se
focalise sur 1939 bien sûr mais aussi
sur les deux premières éditions du
festival à savoir 1946 et 1947
la table ronde a lieu l'après midi à
partir de 14 heures la projection du
film normal dans 15h30
et puis pour finir à 18 heures la visite
commentée de l'exposition par
jean-christophe haglund vice-président
du cercle de gens c'est l'association
plaisir oise lecture et dialogues vous
propose une rencontre littéraire mardi
les sombres avec maylis de kerangal
l'auteur du best-seller réparer les
vivants viendra présenter son dernier
livre un monde à portée de main maylis
de kerangal et beaucoup lui d'un groupe
de lecture et j'ai eu l'occasion de la
rencontrer
dans une conférence littéraire qu'elle
faisait dans une association et je lui
ai proposé de venir nous rencontrer un
plaisir donc elle va nous présenter en
priorité son dernier livre paru en 2018
un monde à portée de main mais elle a
accepté de répondre à nos questions pour
parler de réparer les vivants sont très
beau livre est aussi naissance d'un pont
allait avant de vous laisser quelques
idées de sorties à 50 ans on oublie
1 quatre nominations aux molières la
pièce la ménagerie de verre premier
succès public de tennessee williams se
sera joué sur la scène de la salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux
il y aura également de l'humour ce sera
aux prises à elancourt avec cai ron si
vous êtes amateurs de hip hop
rendez-vous au tec à plaisir avec le
golden stage tour enfin encore du
théâtre à voisins le bretonneux avec la
compagnie but coise clin d'oeil et sa
comédie opéra froch 5 ou l'opéra pour
une banque privée
voici un avant-goût de ce qui vous
attend je suis le narrateur de la pièce
mais aussi à l'un de ses personnages
les autres personnages sont 1ers un
mandat
ma soeur
laura et la jeune talent y apparaît dans
cette finale match mais tu vas aux
chinois de plus en plus tu fais penser à
ton père il sortait jusqu'à pas d'heure
sans aucune explication puis un beau
jour je suis quand même la compagnie ah
ouais ce que vous faisiez vous pardon
vous avez quoi la marque de montres
on n'avait jamais fait ça là c'est une
première voie viable non plus tu n'y
crois pas tape dans tes mains
ce midi hier incroyable j'avais pas
regardé ma montre à l'heure lui quand il
était petit à l'école et écoles dans des
passes de voir s'élever les aliens il en
est ma grand mère tout le remettre dans
une classe incroyable
la date
la coque
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette 8 culture
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour de
nouvelles idées de sorties
[Musique]
m